Transcriber: Jumana Yousef
المدقّق: Riyad Altayeb
أريد أن ابدأ حديثي بمقدمة
جميعنا نقرأ الكتب
وحتى المناهج الدراسية لها مقدمة
ولكننا لا نقرأها
ولكنني ورثت أمرين من أمي
الأمر الأول هو الخدود
والثاني هو المشاعر
إذ يمكن لأمي أن تبكي عندما تُخطف
نصرة في مسلسل سلسال الدم
فالمشاعر التي ستظهر في كلامي
ناتجة عن قانون الوراثة
وليست من فعلي أبدًا
وُلدت في بني نزار
وكان يوم ولادتي أحد أيام الشتاء
وكانت تمطر
ثم حدث شجار من أجل اختيار اسم لي
فتطوع خالي واقترح تسميتي باسم مركّب
فقال: "نسميه زكي بدر لأنه ولد
في 25 كانون الثاني
وهو عيد الشرطة"
في الحقيقة، لا أعلم
لكن أبي قد أظهر له ردة فعل قبيحة
حتى أن خالي لم يستطع أن يخبرني بها
فقرروا تسميتي مازن
قالوا أنه اسم جديد
ولم يكن متداولًا منذ 27 عامًا
فقرروا تسميتي مازن
ثم ذهب أبي إلى الوحدة الصحية
حتى يسميني مازن
فقابل في طريقه معلمة لغة عربية
فقالت: مبروك يا أستاذ محمود
وسألته عن الاسم
فأجابها: إن شاء الله مازن
فقالت له أنا معلمة لغة عربية
ولا أعرف كيف يكتب مازن بالزاي أم بالذال
فذهب أبي إلى الوحدة الصحية
وأخبرهم بأن يكون اسم المولود حازم
وكانت هذه أول مرة لا أكون فيها واعيًا
ولكنها كانت إشارة من عند الله
أن هنالك أشياء لا تحدث ونحن لا ندركها
ولكنها موجودة ومكتوبة
ولمّا كان عمري 10 سنوات
عمي -رحمه الله- وعمي هو الذي شكّل عقلي
بعد أبي ونجيب محفوظ
سألني: ماذا تريد أن تصبح؟
ولأنني كنت أحب كرة القدم
أجبته: أريد أن أصبح لاعب كرة قدم
فسألني: هل أنت موهوب في الكرة؟
فقلت: ليس كثيرًا
ثم سألني عن أكثر شيء موهوب به؟
ففكرت وتذكرت أنني في امتحان التعبير
كنت أحصل على 10/10
فقلت الكتابة
فسألني: لمن تقرأ؟
فأجبته أنني لا أقرأ لأحد
فأخبرني أن أقرأ لنجيب محفوظ
ويحيى حقي ومحمد عفيفي
أنا لم أسمع هذه الأسماء إلا في الأفلام
وبدأت القراءة
وأحببت القراءة جدًا
وصرت أراها كعالم ثانٍ
غير العالم الذي أعيش فيه
ثم درست مثل أي طالب
كان حلمه أن يحقق أمنية أهله
ويدخل الطب
وحصلت على معدل 93%
ودخلت تجارة إنجليزي
أخبروني أن كتب التجارة تكون مستوردة
وفيها إعلانات كوكا كولا
فأحسست أنني سأكون شخصًا محترمًا
إذا سجلت تجارة أنجليزي
تخرجت من التجارة
ومن المفترض أن أعمل في بنك
حتى ترى أمي أنني في وظيفة مستقرة
وأحصل على راتب
وأحصل على تأمينات
قدمت للعمل في جميع البنوك
ثم اتصل بي شخص من مجلة "عين"
وأخبرني أنهم بحاجة لصحفيين
وأنني أكتب بشكل جيد
وافقت وذهبت للعمل في القاهرة
وعندما سألته عن الراتب
أخبرني أن الراتب موجود في كشف الإنتاج
كشف الإنتاج تستطيع أن تجد فيه
عدد الكلمات التي كتبتها في الشهر
وتحصل على مال بناءً على عددها
كنت أحصل على راتب 300 جنيه في الشهر
كانت وجبتي اليومية هي الكشري
الكشري بالنسبة لي هو معنى الحياة
فيه كل شيء
فيه أرز، معكرونة، عدس وتقلية
ولو كنت في مطعم بسيط
سيقدم لك الخبز مع طبق الكشري
ولو كنت في مطعم أقل مستوى
سيقدم لك الطماطم معه
وعندما كنت أتناول طبق الكشري حتى أشبع
اتصلت بي سيدة وسألتني إذا كنت حازم محمود
وأنني قمت بقتديم طلب توظيف للبنك الأهلي
وأنني قدمت الاختبار
وأن موعد الكشف الطبي هو يوم الأحد
لأنهم وافقوا على توظيفي في البنك الأهلي
فكرت في أمي
وأنها ستكون سعيدة جدًا عندما أخبرها
قلت للسيدة: أتشرف، شكرًا
ولكنني لا أقدر أن أحلق شعري كل يوم
وأن أحلق ذقني
وأضع ربطة العنق أيضًا
اعتقدت السيدة أنني أمزح
وقالت لي: شكرًا على المزحة
لكن موعد الكشف الطبي يوم الأحد
قلت لها: أنني آسف ولا أريد الذهاب
وأنني أريد البقاء وإكمال وظيفتي هنا
في الحقيقة أعتقد أن أمي تلومني
على اتخاذ هذا القرار حتى هذا اليوم
لكنني قررت أن أستمر في طريقي
وبالمناسبة كان أول موضوع عملته في الصحافة
كان مئوية نجيب محفوظ
وتذكرت عمي -رحمه الله-
عندما أخبرني بأن أقرأ في البداية
لنجيب محفوظ
ثم حاولت أن أكتب مجموعات قصصية وكتب
بعدها كتبت كتاب
مجموعة قصصية اسمها أم عويس
وكان ضمن مشروع أُطلقَ بعد ثورة يناير
كان اسمه النشر لمن يستحق
فكتبت الكتاب وتم نشره
وكان هنالك مكتبة اسمها ألف في الإسكندرية
قررت أن تقيم حفل توقيع للكتاب
وكنت حينها مقيمًا في بني مزار
وسافرت إلى حفل التوقيع
كانت مقدمة الحفل شابة اسمها هبة محمود خميس
وكانت زميلتي بالكتابة في موقع اسمه بص وطل
كان حفل التوقيع في عام 2011
في عام 2014 أصبحت هبة خميس زوجتي
وفي عام 2016 كان لدينا طفل اسمه يحيى
ثم استمرت الحياة
استمرّت بالحب
ومن فترة قريبة، كنت أكلم صديقًا لي
واكتشفت أن زوجته تعاني من سرطان الثدي
صديقي اسمه محمد
فقلت له: من المؤكد أن هنالك إشارة ما
قد بعثها الله لك
لكنه قال لي: لا أرى أية إشارات يا حازم
أجبته: قد يريد الله أن يخبرك بشيء معين
فقال: لا أرى أن الله يريد أن يخبرني شيئًا
ثم سألني: ما الذي تأكله الآن؟
أذكر أنه كان عيد الأضحى
فقلت له: أنني آكل ريّش (لحمة) وكفتة
ثم قال لي: أنها محرومة من هذا الأكل
ثم قال: في النهاية أظن أنك تمزح معي
فأجبت:هنالك أديب ليبي اسمه إبراهيم الكوني
يقول أن الإشارات هي لغة الله
فسيكون من الأكيد أن الله قد بعث لك إشارة
لكنه قال لي أنه لا أرى أية إشارات حقيقةً
وبعد أسبوعين تقريبًا
كنت أمشي في الشارع وأصابني الدوار
وقال لي صديقي:
يجب عليك الذهاب إللى الطبيب لتفحص
وكان لدي سعال شديد
فذهبت لأفحص
وطلب مني الطبيب أن أسحب عينة للفحص
وسحبت عينة من أجل الفحص
وقال لي الطبيب: أنت مصاب بالليمفوما
فسألته: ماذا يعني "ليمفوما"؟
فأجابني بأنه ورم سرطاني
في الحقيقة، أنني في هذه اللحظة
دائمًا في تلك المواقف
يرى كل شخص فينا صورة أمامه
أنا رأيت صديقي وهو يخرج لسانه من فمه
وهو يقول لي: هل ترى أية إشارة يا حازم؟
هل ترى أية علامة؟
وفي الحقيقة
لم أكن قادرًا وقتها على تحديد شعوري
وبدأت العلاج
بدأت أتعالج بالكيماوي
والكيماوي شيء سخيف
ولونه أحمر
ولما كنت في المستشفى
وأرى المحلول ذو اللون الأحمر
ينزل ويدخل في جسدي
كان أبي، وأمي، وأختي، وزوجتي جالسين أمامي
هذا قانون الوراثة الذي أخبرتكم عنه
في البداية
وأصدقائي
اكتشفت أنني لا أستطيع الاستغناء عنهم
وأنه يجب علي إكمال حياتي
وأن الحياة حلوة
وأنه يجب علي إكمال العلاج
فأكملت العلاج
وأخدت ستة جلسات كيماوي
وقع شعري
وكانت هذه هي المرة الثانية
التي أرى صديقي وهو يخرج لسانه
أنا شخص معتد بشعره كثيرًا
مع أن شعري قد يعد أسوأ شعر
على وجه البسيطة
لكنني كنت معتدًا به جدًا
وكنت أحبه جدًا
وكنت أحب ذقني جدًا
وفي اللحظة التي ذهبت بها لحلق شعري وذقني
هي كانت أصعب لحظة، أصعب من جلسات الكيماوي
ولما ذهبت لحلق شعري
كنت أرى صديقي في مرآة الحلاق
الحلاق كان يحلق لي
وصديقي يخرج لسانه في المرآة
وقال لي: أنا لا أرى أية إشارات
لكنني انتهيت من العلاج
ولقد تعافيت تقريبًا الحمد لله
وصلت إلى فكرة أن الدائرة القريبة هي الأهم
وأن أهم شيء هم الناس الموجودين
من حولك ويحبونك
ولما كنت في المستشفى
وأرى وأفكر في الدائرة الموجودة من حولي
أدركت أنني لا أريد الاستغناء عنهم
وأنهم هم لن يستغنوا عني
وأنني سأتعالج وسأكمل الطريق
حتى يبقى الذين أحبهم معي وحولي
الحياة حلوة
وحبوا الحياة
ولا أريد أن أكون كإبراهيم الفقي
وأقول كلام في التنمية البشرية وكلام آخر
لكن الحياة فعلًا حلوة
والحياة لن تعاش إلا بشيء واحد
هو الحب
شكرًا